in a post-911 world
the field of forensic science has become
more urgent and important than ever
deaths related to global terrorism have
spiked and in 2015 alone more than
29,000 people were killed as a result of
terrorist attacks the pervasive threat
of mass casualty terror attacks demands
new innovations in forensics especially
when it comes to how we investigate
large-scale blast sites samples of these
can be taken and sent for DNA analysis
Kim Moran is an instructor at Arcadia
University who works with FBI agents
police bomb squads and forensic
scientists and how to best respond to
the aftermath of a bombing when a blast
happens it's so important to be able to
identify all the victims that are
involved so that we can return those
remains back to the family in terms of
personal effects people we're very kind
of easily to distinguish jewelry so this
could really help identify the
individual debris from a blast can also
be used to identify the perpetrator a
crucial first step in identifying any
links to terror organizations but before
this evidence gets to the lab it has to
be collected in the field and training
for that is where the challenges of
living in a radically new world lead to
some radical new solutions I've come to
Pennsylvania to shadow Kim as she takes
students through her unorthodox approach
to learning the intricacies of post
blast investigation we're in a parking
lot and a group of students are dressing
dead animals up behind us what's
happening we have a bus today where
we're sending a charge and we have a
number of passengers on that vehicle we
can't use human cadavers yes
and this is our next best thing
previously deceased animals so these are
the passengers essentially these are the
passengers you know using a mannequin
it's just not going to be affected by
the blast in the same way as an actual
biological entity it's really important
for first responders to have really the
full realistic experience of going out
to a post blast investigation with the
sites and the smell
the sounds that would happen for real
incidents such as saddles are real the
smells are very real yes to mimic
real-world evidence gathering the
students create a fake identity for each
animal Madison Kelly Wow you literally
put lipstick on a figure and outfit them
accordingly the personal effects that
were including will help the responders
positively identify the individuals some
of the stuff that would seem a little
absurd about what's happening behind us
that's actually happening because you
are trying as much as possible to
recreate exactly family members are
gonna see something happen on television
and they're going to wonder if their son
or daughter or husband or wife was
involved in any way what is this a sheet
she's actually an expecting mother
okay as the day swings into gear the
students load up the animals and put
them in place on the bus at the blast
site a 3d scanner is also on hand to map
the site before and after the blast
captures a million points a second as it
scans and is able to deliver a very
quick summary of what happened at that
scene but there's no experiment without
an explosion enter the local bomb
experts who board the bus and set the
explosive device so on one hand we're
here at the forefront of a pretty
important experiment in modern day
forensic science on the other hand I'm
standing here in front of a school bus
that's filled with dead farm animals
dressed up in human clothes and they're
about to be blown to smithereens no no
three two one
to the untrained eye this is just pure
and total chaos
the search team must quickly sift
through the rubble to mark any evidence
that could help identify the animals on
the box like body parts or personal
effects no matter how small from a
cigarette butt you could get a DNA
profile even a stray piece of plastic
could be a bomb fragment that may help
identify the killer anything on a bus
that looks like this as the
investigators work the ground the 3d
scanner provides a detailed study of
where each piece of evidence originated
and where it ended up finally the bodies
are removed from the site and the
evidence is collected to send to the lab
experiments like this are really
important because not something that
people see on a daily basis but it's
going to happen we just don't know when
we don't know where so we need to be
prepared for it because when an incident
like this does happen the skills these
students are learning become the crucial
tools that can provide critical
real-time answers to both law
enforcement and victims families
[Music]